africa's billionaires are richer than
they've been in years despite the global
pandemic
as a group the continent's 18
billionaires are worth an estimated 84.9
billion dollars a 15 increase from 12
months ago
soaring stock prices lifted the fortunes
of these tycoons as demands for products
from cement to luxury goods ticked up
for the 11th year in a row aliko dangote
of nigeria is the continent's richest
person worth an estimated 13.9 billion
dollars up from 12.1 billion dollars
last year following a 30 increase in the
stock price of dengote cement his most
valuable asset
analysts found a surge in housing
developments in nigeria and growth in
government infrastructure spending drove
higher demand for cement in the first
nine months of 2021. jumping into the
number two spot up for number four last
year is luxury goods magnate johann
rupert of south africa shares of his
company financiary richmond maker of
cartier watches in mont blanc pens
surged more than 60 and pushed his
fortune to 11 billion dollars up from
7.2 billion dollars a year ago making
him the biggest dollar gainer on the
list south african nikki oppenheimer who
formerly ran diamond mining firm to
beers before selling it to mining firm
anglo-american a decade ago ranks number
three worth an estimated 8.7 billion
dollars
the biggest gainer in percentage terms
is drive masayuwa of zimbabwe worth 2.7
billion dollars up from 1.2 billion
dollars last year a 125 increase
shares of econet wireless zimbabwe which
he founded rose more than 750 in the
past year helping to drive up the size
of his fortune the 18 billionaires from
africa hail from seven different
countries south africa and egypt each
have five billionaires followed by
nigeria with three in morocco with two
all of the continent's billionaires are
men the last woman to appear in the
ranks isabel dos santos of angola fell
off the forbes list in january 2021
[Music]
you